all right today's draft hyper speed most
important defensive players for super
bowl 55 chris ask me the question let's
see if i get it right probably not all
right you know the national anthem was
whitney houston in super bowl 25
half time who performed first there was
a george w bush
speech because of the gulf war but do
you remember who performed half time at
super bowl 25
george h.w bush it was yes sorry sorry
was super bowl super bowl 25 was not the
michael jackson super bowl
um
man no i don't know i i have no idea
that was before they i was there i have
no idea
yeah up with people singers i don't know
whoa whoa whoa
the new kids on the block that's the
only song i can remember right now how
in the world would i have known that
okay you get the first pick
okay well i think the guy that i'm gonna
go with right off the bat
is chris jones i'm gonna make him my
number one pick chris jones to me first
off is the best defense alignment in
this football game
you know the kansas city chiefs yes they
like the blitz but i would got to think
with the way the buccaneers played
towards the end of the year their way
they're past protecting they keep guys
in the block a lot
that you got to be careful about over
blitzing tampa because they're going to
have max protection on some of these
times and then have great time to throw
the ball with a numbers benefit in the
past game chris jones to me
the ability to stop fournette and jones
in the run game but can he get in
brady's face up the middle he wasn't
real successful in that first matchup i
think he'll have to play a little bit
better this time around if they want to
win the game
for me if i had the first pick it would
have been jones the obvious second pick
though devin white he's the guy that is
the heart and soul of the tampa bay
defense as he goes that defense goes he
sets the tone he's chippy not too chippy
he's in your face he's not too in your
face and i could see him maybe trying to
just trying to to give you know travis
kelsey or somebody just a little bit of
the business early on just to make sure
that that those guys know that that they
got a rough and tumble crew that's going
to be coming after them all day long
yeah i hear that definitely any to where
i look at devon white that you know the
travis kelsey underneath like you said
the running back throws underneath and
the other one too mike as much as we've
talked about mahomes and the sprinting
out either way right he's going to have
a big play in that even stopping him to
run but also as he sprints out will he
be able to play those crossers and not
be manipulated by mahomes eyes and
everything like that i'm gonna go to
carlton davis tampa bay corner number 24
as my next pick
he struggled you know the first time
around we know that yeah tyree killed
burnt him one you know a few few verse
man-to-man coverage a few were in zone
coverage carlton davis is better now
than he was then but certainly
you know his play is going to dictate
how successful the buccaneers are
they're going to have to roll the dice
i'm gonna go with tyron matthew the
chief safety he's a lot like devon white
in that he's got that instinct of where
the ball may be a timely defensive play
is going to be the potential backbreaker
if this turns into a shootout somebody's
got to break serve at some point and
tyron matthew would be a candidate to be
a guy to pop up in the right spot at the
right time and get his hands on a tom
brady football is it my pick here we got
is it
round three most offensive most
important defensive player or most
defensive important player in super bowl
55
i'm going to go to a guy that just got
infused into the tampa lineup and just
got healthy and vitaveya i i am going to
go we know the pass rushers on the edge
jpp and shaq barrett of course are very
important i want to pick them i know
that i got to think there's going to be
a concerted effort to move my homes the
speed sweeps all those things to slow
those guys down make them hesitate a
little bit but vida veya in the middle
that's the one where i look at can he
push the pocket get in mahomes face to
where if mahomes has nowhere to move up
and slide that way
that's where it could get dicey with
those two other guys coming around the
edge and then collapsing the pocket
there
i i i think he's a phenomenal football
player and i think you're going to hear
his name called a few times on sunday
the chiefs have really been
underrepresented in this draft i feel
like i should take another one to
balance it out right now it's three to
two not really underrepresented but it's
going to be four to two because i'm
going antoine winfield jr because look
if he doesn't make that play on jared
cook in the divisional round the bucks
are may not be here it may have been
27-13 in the third quarter of that game
just a nose for the football instincts
tough gritty just like his dad was and
you know this is his opportunity on a
stage i don't think his dad ever made it
to i'd have to go back and look at all
the various years i don't think he
played so many years chances are he
would have made it his kid makes it his
first season i don't think he ever did i
i just think that that he's got that
that factor that it that intangible
thing that's going to put him in
position to make a big play when the
buccaneers need it chris
yeah i mean they certainly they need him
to be healthy and ready to go it seems
like it's all signs pointing him to
playing right mike i haven't heard
anything this week but i would be
shocked if he's not and they need all
hands on deck especially in the
secondary you got to deal with this
group this weapons mahomes andy reed
with two weeks to prepare you know
that's gonna be a lot for that
buccaneers defense to deal with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports